- How's it going, Keith?
(swoops)
- Oh, it's good.
How are you doing?
- I'm doing awesome.
- Where are we going?
- So, we're going to Vegas!
- (laughing) We're going to Vegas?
- Let's go (laughing)!
Woohoo!
- We can't just go to the
(upbeat funky music)
Okay, well I think
I packed okay for that.
- So Steven brought me
in the car yesterday
and just said, "We're going
somewhere, pack your bags."
You haven't really told
me why we're in Vegas.
- We had such a great time
on that sushi adventure.
- Yeah, we had a great time.
(rewinding)
- Who's your boy?
- Steven Lim
- (laughing) Yes!
- I was like, "We gotta do part two."
- So today we're gonna get
three types of burgers,
(swooping)
a cheap one, a medium-priced one,
and a super expensive one.
In fact, it's gonna be $777.
- (sneezing) Oh, I'm
allergic to that idea.
(laughs)
- But we're gonna find out,
"Is that burger really
worth the price difference?"
- I like cheap burgers.
- Maybe you just haven't
had the right experience yet
with the right person.
- I like that you've made that about you.
- Well, isn't this all about me, Keith?
- No, it's not.
It's literally a video
comparing burgers.
- With Keith and Steven,
best buddies for life!
(upbeat jazzy music)
- I'm Adam Baird, the
Executive Corporate Chef
for Habit Burger Grill.
Keith and Steven are out in Las Vegas
enjoying our delicious Charburger.
We cook everything to order,
and we season it with a handmade seasoning
in the back of the house.
We caramelize onions all day long,
toast our buns to order.
Every little bit of detail
has to be executed with the utmost skill.
(bell dings)
- It is gorgeous, I don't want
to waste any time talking.
Let's eat it.
- It smells so good right now.
- I don't wanna waste any time talking.
Let's eat it.
- Where the sun's coming down.
- I'm not waiting.
(paper crinkles)
- Oh, it's so juicy!
- Very savory.
- The mayonnaise was like this great layer
of delightful goodness.
- Your reaction after
taking a bite of this
is to take (chuckling) another
bite immediately (chuckles).
- This drink is delicious.
- Also, they make their
own strawberry limeade here
and it's (bleeps) great.
- Just go back and forth.
- Perfect balance, like a Olympic gymnast.
- You're perfect, Keith.
- Together we are the perfect dynamic duo!
- Oh.
- And this burger is $4.15.
- That's crazy.
What would you compare this value to?
Theft?
$4.15.
You can't beat this burger.
But the next burger is
not $4, it's 20 bucks.
So we gotta go there.
- Bring your family here,
bring a date.
(record screeches)
- Why do you cut me off?
I had such a nice rounding.
- Okay, go ahead.
Go!
- I tried to end the segment
and then I had to start
over with a new bow.
Why is this happening?
You're not going to find.
- (yells then laughs)
(crew laughs)
- Damn, that was a fine burger.
- Burger Fact!
- How many burgers did
America eat in 2014?
- This is a question, this is not a fact.
- That's trivia.
- You can't say "Burger
Fact," and ask me a question!
- How many burgers (laughing).
- Goddamnit, (lauging) that's a question!
(spring boings)
- did America eat in 2014?
- I don't know!
200 thousand.
- What?
Are you stupid?
- I don't, I'm guessing.
I was awaiting a fact.
- Nine billion.
So on our way now to
the Gordon Ramsay BurGR.
- Wouldn't mind some bacon.
I don't think we'll meet Gordon,
but we'll certainly meet somebody.
- I'm driving without hands, Keith.
- It worries me.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- We are at Gordon Ramsay BurGR.
Our featured burger today
that we're talking
about is our Hog Burger.
This is the only burger
that we actually griddle,
so we get a lot more caramelization on it.
Our buns, they're all
brushed with 83% butter fat,
and they are toasted on the griddle.
Our cabbage slaw is dressed
with a tarragon mayonnaise.
A nice, beautifully
caramelized pork patty.
On top of our pork is our
smoked barbecue brisket.
- [Steven] On top of the pork.
- Pork on pork on pork.
Then comes our crispy
onions, garlic seasoning,
paprika, and a little
bit of cayenne for kick,
and we also need the acid of our pickles,
so these are our house-made
bread and butter pickles.
- Massive.
- [Keith] It's almost as big as your head.
- [Harold] The best thing
about a burger is it's simple.
Everyone can identify with it
but the way that you can take it
through the roof is in the details.
- When I eat burgers that
are this big, I smash them.
- You are an animal.
How are you going to enjoy
the flavors like that?
- How are you going to enjoy
the flavors separately?
Cheers.
- Cheers.
- Wow.
It's very, very porky.
But with the onions and the
pickle, totally counters that.
- Combine this many ingredients and put it
into one item that you can enjoy together
is a very hard task.
And they managed to do that.
- Balanced like a pig
on a tightrope, baby.
- If I'm going to spend $18,
I want to see this much food.
- It was as big as Steven's head,
but a really sexy Steven's head.
- Are you sure that's not
just this guy right here?
- Nah, I'm pretty sure.
Two little piggies with Steven
Lim heads on a tightrope.
I want to see that animation now.
(playful music)
(oinking)
If you were staying anywhere
near Planet Hollywood,
and you want a bomb-ass burger,
this is just incredible.
Now we gotta head to
this preposterous burger.
- What would make this
next burger worth it?
- I guess it'd have to be the best tasting
burger I've ever had.
- That's not hard to do, right?
- It is hard to do.
I've eaten more burgers
than any other food.
It's too expensive.
- No amount of money
can buy the friendship
that we have together, Keith.
Do you hear that?
- Yep.
- We're best buddies.
- I bet all the people
on the internet are so
envious of our friendship.
(grand symphonic music)
- What we're looking at
today is our 777 Burger.
The best hamburger in town.
- It's 777 dollars?
- It is.
- That is the most expensive
burger I've ever heard of.
- And champagne.
- And champagne, right.
- Cause it comes with Dom Perignon.
That burger gets a Wagyu
patty, aged goat cheese,
pancetta bacon,
- Oh my God.
- [Karl] foie gras, arugula, lobster,
and it gets 100-year old
aged balsamic vinegar.
- [Keith] How much is a bottle?
- [Karl] This goes for
about $200 a bottle.
- [Keith] I'm looking at it, I'm like
every single item on
there is more expensive
than a thing I would normally eat.
- [Karl] You've gotta
live once in a while.
- I know, I've gotta live!
I'm.
- Ya gotta live.
(romantic piano music)
- We are about to eat
the greatest thing in the world.
- For once I'm not super
upset that you're touching me
because I too am very excited.
That's not an invitation to re-grab.
- Good afternoon, gentleman.
I just wanted to stop
by and offer you first,
our bottle of Dom Perignon Rose,
and this goes exquisitely
with the finest burger
on the planet, the 777 Burger.
- [Steven] Yes.
- [Waiter] You made a wonderful
decision today, gentlemen.
Enjoy your meal.
- I also like how romantic this is
that we're gonna share everything.
It's very cute, I like it.
- Yeah, I'm sorry,
I couldn't afford more than one burger.
- No, I understand.
- Which was actually my plan all along.
You eat it first, Keith, I can't.
- [Keith] You sure?
- I don't feel worthy.
- Well, well, well.
- I want some of that champagne, though.
- Oh, that's delightful.
Oh, that's good.
- Holy (bleeps).
- I'm going for it.
(piano music crescendos)
Wow.
Steven that is crazy tasting.
- I had so much pleasure just
watching you eat that burger.
- It's really good (chuckles).
- I don't want to eat it.
- Eat it.
- I can't.
- You can.
- I feel, I physically
cannot eat this burger.
- Alright.
- I would feel bad.
(piano music slows)
(gasps)
I'm tearing up watching you eat this.
- Dude, it's so good.
Balsamic vinegar is truly,
like, God tears.
- I'm doing it.
(piano music crescendos)
- It's a little overwhelming.
- Wow.
- Every item on here
has a strong flavor.
- The goat cheese and the beef
really meld together well.
It's like one true pair.
Like Keith and Steven, all together.
You know, it's best buddies for life.
- He's insane.
Let's not kid ourselves.
That's a lotta money.
But if you're in a place
to spend lots of money,
you might as well go for it.
I didn't think that a burger
could be an experience until today.
- I don't want this ever to end.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- So, what was your favorite?
- If I were to come back to Vegas
and bring my girlfriend
somewhere, it would have to be
the Gordon Ramsay Burger.
(bell rings)
It was something super different
and it was just a really good burger.
- I'm gonna start going to the Habit.
However, the best burger I had today was
the 777 Burger.
(bell rings)
- To share bites of that
burger, it's worth it.
- It's Vegas, baby!
(trumpet screeches)
- Did not do that.
(funky jazz music)
- I'm gonna go to bed.
- [Keith] It's 5:30 in Vegas.
You can sleep, but I'm getting (bleep) up.
- No.
- It's Vegas, baby!
- [Steven] Stop (laughing), god!
What is wrong with you?
(Keith roaring and laughing)
- Get (bleep) up and die (laughing).
Las Vegas, baby!
- Alright, you're scaring me.
I'm going to sleep.
(metal squeaking)
- Vegas, baby.